PENGUINS, GETS IN ON VASILEVSKIY
AND TRIES TO DEKE HIM LIKE EVAN
RODRIGUES DID EARLIER.
VASILEVSKIY PUTS IT ASIDE.
BUT THE PENGUINS QUICK THROUGH
THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE,
GENERATING SOME OFFENSE IN THAT
REGARD.
SEAN: FIRST LINE OUT FOR EACH
SIDE.
IT WAS A PENALTY-FREE FIRST
PERIOD.
AND PITTSBURGH WINS ANOTHER
DRAW, THIS TIME FROM JEFF
CARTER.
BACKHANDED BACK IN DEEP BY BRYAN
RUST.
CARTER BLOCKED.
PLAY BY VASILEVSKIY.
AND A GOAL!
SLOPPY PLAY BY VASILEVSKIY, AND
IT WAS CENTERED BY CARTER RIGHT
ONTO THE STICK OF HEINEN, WHO
HAS A GOAL IN HIS PITTSBURGH
PENGUINS DEBUT.
RAY: HEINEN WAS ONE OF THOSE
VERY FEW PENGUIN ADDITIONS IN
THE OFFSEASON, PLAYED LAST YEAR
IN ANAHEIM.
DIFFICULT YEAR.
SAID HE WANTED TO SHOOT THE PUCK
MORE THIS YEAR, TRUST HIS SHOT.
WELL, THIS IS AN EASY ONE
BECAUSE JEFF CARTER MAKES A
TERRIFIC PLAY TO SEAL THE WALL.
AND VASILEVSKIY TRIES TO THROW
IT AROUND THE BOARDS.